- [Instructor] Right over
here, we have the recipe
for super cake, which you
want to make for your guests
that are coming over for dinner tonight.
But this recipe right over here,
this is for 32 people.
This would serve 32 folks.
But, you only have 16 guests coming over.
So, if you only have
16 guests coming over,
what should be your ingredients here?
How much of each of these
ingredients should you have?
I encourage you to pause the
video and think about it.
Right now, we're gonna think about, well,
we're gonna have a slightly
smaller super cake.
Smaller super,
super cake.
You might have reasoned that,
"Look, if we're going to
have half as many guests,
"then each of the ingredients,
"we should just have half as much."
And you would be right.
Instead of eight eggs, for
our smaller super cake,
you could have four eggs.
Instead of six cups of flour,
in our smaller super cake,
you could have three cups of flour.
Instead of six cups of sugar,
you could have three cups of sugar.
I'm just taking half of
each of these numbers.
Instead of two cups of butter,
you could have one cup of butter.
Instead of six teaspoons of baking soda,
you could have three
teaspoons of baking soda.
And, last but not least,
instead of two cups of water,
you could have one cup of water.
Now, this will work and this is actually
how you should adjust recipes.
But there's something
interesting about what's similar
about these two recipes.
The recipe for the main super
cake that feeds 32 people
and the recipe for the smaller super cake.
And that's the notion of ratios.
The ratios between ingredients
or the ratio of how much of an ingredient
you need for given guests.
For example, you can see here
that for every eight eggs,
you have six cups of flour.
So, let me write this down.
So, for
every
eight eggs
we have six cups of flour.
We have
six cups of flour.
Which can be expressed as a ratio of,
the ratio of eggs to flour is 8:6.
Which is, once again, interpreted
as for every eight eggs,
I have six cups of flour.
If I said for every six cups
of flour, I have eight eggs,
I would've written 6:8.
So, the order here matters.
But here I'm saying the ratio
of eggs to flour, of eggs
to cups of flour is 8:6.
For every eight eggs, I
have six cups of flour.
Well, what about for the smaller cake?
Well, here,
for every four eggs,
we have three cups of flour.
We have
three cups
of flour.
So, what would this ratio be?
Well, for every four eggs,
we have three cups of flour.
So, the ratio of eggs to flour is 4:3.
Now, turns out that these
are the exact same ratio.
If you have eight eggs for
every six cups of flour,
or for every eight eggs
you have six cups of flour,
that's the same thing
as for every four eggs,
you have three cups of flour.
What you're just doing is
taking each of these numbers
and you are dividing it by two.
So, you could say the
ratio in either case,
the ratio of eggs to flour,
let me write this down.
The ratio
of eggs,
eggs,
to two cups of flour.
Let me write two
cups of flour.
Cups of flour.
In either case is,
is four eggs
for every three cups of flour.
This is going to be
true for either recipe.
You have the same ratio.
If you have eight eggs here,
so, for every four eggs, you
have three cups of flour.
Well, that means your going
to have six cups of flour.
This is why ratios are helpful.
This recipe has a
different number of eggs,
a different number of cups of flour,
a different number of cups of sugar.
But the ratios between the
ingredients are the same.
So, you will be able to have
a cake that tastes the same,
that essentially is the same cake
but just is a different size.